what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch the first episode of star wars
visions we decided we're going to watch
the english version because it just
makes watching the reactions with us
that much easier to do plus i hear they
got some pretty good voice actors
involved so just makes sense let's do it
we're americans but ladies and gentlemen
if you haven't enjoyed our reaction
would really appreciate if you go ahead
and hit that like button also be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next star wars visions is up
we're gonna be shooting a lot of these
back to back so hopefully we get all
these reactions out for you over the
next few days and lastly as always full
length watch long as we sync up with the
time coder over at our patreon page over
there we cover so many shows with the
same tier you get the option for both
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included just finished avatar the last
airbender thank you for all the support
you guys are showing our way and of
course jade thank you so much writing
down these highlights for us you sexy
beast you yeah
don't sue me for guy hitting on his
employee
all right
[Music]
the duel
[Laughter]
wow
[Laughter]
droid
uh
oh
thank you very much sir
it must be lonesome traveling the
countryside all by yourself
god's soundtrack
[Applause]
some strong kurosawa vibes here
absolutely last remnants of the war
willing to take whatever they want it's
not safe we should go inside
come here thanks for the warm welcome
it's time for you to pay your taxes that
was a direct order which one of you is
the chief
i am the current chief and you've taken
another oh
you're really the chief of this village
who did your father run away and leave
you in charge what a coward your father
must be
i've
oh
i thought his face was kind of smashed
now sleeping
sleeping it off
you know you can't
right
wow
[Laughter]
do i care do i not care
disgraceful i love the colored lights
too
oh hello
what do we do
my droid do you think you could repair
him
[Laughter]
i need him fully operational by the time
this pot boils
cool
[Laughter]
run don't engage in close combat
oh
did you honestly think you could stand a
chance against a dark lord
oh no
no
show that [ __ ] what's up
you don't look like one of the villagers
who dares face me
just a simple wonder
i'm gonna hurry
[Laughter]
you just turn the tee down
what
oh
cool
you're a jedi
it's been a long time since i killed a
jedi
[Music]
unfortunately i am not a jedi
whoa
[Music]
hey yeah cool
raiders
the same creature as sibobar
[Music]
oh i have so many nipples
i've grew more nipples for the chills
we have the chief and his guards have
surrendered
apologies but we don't fight fair either
drop your weapon
i love it i love it so much
[Music]
table's about to turn
[Music]
look at that droid
[Music]
he can't swim
there you go
what a shot
please sir are you willing to tell me
your name
[Music]
so it collects like the crystals off of
other people's take care of this
interesting it wards off evil
sith kyber crystals
i have spoken
[Music]
i love the choice to do this in black
and white too
yeah well like what they chose to put in
color
that was that was fantastic
yeah it was like beautiful that was
amazing
i really love that a lot
oh yeah really beautiful
style oh it's already shaping up to be
exactly what i wanted to do absolutely
all right let's talk about it well that
was great that was almost everything i
wanted it to be i believe that and and i
kind of got the vibe too from looking at
certain images from the trailer that
this particular episode is most likely
inspired by the kurosawa film because a
lot of times you know star wars will has
often referenced kirisawa
usually seven samurai but i believe the
movie that this one is based off of is
yo jimbo is that i don't know how to
proper it's a different name in the
states let me tell you
but i think it's i think it's called the
ojimbo uh i've never seen that movie but
i've seen enough people compare star
wars to that movie to then draw a
correlation
to uh here when looking at the episode
so yeah it's a movie i should definitely
watch i know
uh but
in terms of what they do with this
episode i thought it was really cool you
know because
not only did they captured aesthetically
like that film i'm presuming you know
but they do capture the overall tone of
being a ronin
it also did uh the plot of uh the movie
that i wanted to do the star wars film
that i had in my yeah i had a two-hour
one in mind but but there's a lot of
different details it's better at 12
but it's essentially like yeah i wanted
it to be like an anime samurai movie um
but about a a guy who is a former sith
uh but without going into details but
it's pretty much like the same kind of
plot like oh goes to town saves the town
yeah something's really grounded and you
know obviously longer and more character
development blah blah blah blah blah but
yeah that is the uh i was like so for me
i'm like oh this is hitting all the
right feels and especially with choosing
the aesthetic of black and white
created this gray area because i thought
it was cool how like there was a very
few colors that you had here but the
colors that it had were obviously the
black and white creating the gray
but then you have uh you know like the
red but then beyond that too it's like
there were certain little bulbs around
you that were like blue and green
representing like light and dark side
and how this character falls into the
gray area of that man who presumably
former sith
um
now lives this
this uh path that is not exactly fully
light or fully dark you know so i
thought like the color palette choice of
that was really cool then you know a
bunch of familiar star wars creatures
here or there you know one droid looked
like uh the one from the mandalorian
zero and then another one was
there was another one uh that look
there's another creature i look like i
see i don't know there's like a tuscan
raider there's a tuscany i barely i
don't like tuscany i don't remember two
minutes
i remember too many of the creatures i
remember like they did the names i don't
remember doing any of the titles of the
creatures there's one look like sababa
at one point yeah um which was neat
because then you start going into the
fight between them and it's called the
duel and it's it sounded like their song
was a play on duel of the fates yeah
interpolation with more japanese
instrumentation fleshing it out yeah it
was cool uh but i love the tone and i
love the mood and i thought they brought
the samurai spirit to life and honestly
from seeing the trailers i was like this
is
this is delivering already on what i
want it to be uh so far you know it's
like a cool little slice
but yeah john what'd you think yeah i
loved this and i think i would
absolutely echo that sentiment that like
this is exactly the kind of thing i was
hoping for i love that this was not very
dependent i mean there's some dialogue
some good voice performances i believe
lucy liu was the
uh like main adversarial character but
uh i i liked that it wasn't dependent on
a lot of dialogue or anything like that
very visual storytelling when the
flashes of color started to come up i
thought those were used really nicely
especially because there's so much color
coding in star wars even you know all
the light side colors have different
individual meanings and things like that
and it's just they made it so tangible
and yeah like it in its story depiction
does feel like a kurosawa movie but also
i love that they combined the aesthetics
of having both old film just like
scratched up and you can see like hairs
ticking by but they also it looked by
the animation like they were doing this
in a blend of things that were drawn and
things that were sort of cg enhanced but
what i loved is they really put in that
old time feel of a drawing where it's
like all the shadows and all the ink
blots feel like they're moving because
every individual image is different yeah
and it feels very drawn by hand so it's
like you get the old film aesthetic and
the old animation aesthetic together
and something that yeah is like a total
mood piece and then the music also
really reminded me of an old kurosawa
movie when you got away from some of the
star wars i thought they blended it
really well so you had some of these big
sweeping romantic orchestral notes
obviously duel of the fates calling
directly back and then some of these
more obscure stringed instruments or
flute-like instruments that really just
added so much atmosphere so yeah and i
mean i'm a sucker for anything in in
black and white that's like presented
like anything new that's presented that
way so i i really enjoyed the heck out
of this yeah it was awesome but of
course you know you can't end this
without talking about how they take all
like the japanese film influences and
slap it into star wars right down to the
fact of how we that the blade is
protruded like it goes away like it
doesn't it doesn't suck into the handle
yeah he actually has to put it away like
a real sword yeah like a real blade
which is awesome
even even the blade handle of it didn't
look like a lightsaber it looked like an
actual sword yeah and uh would you say
and the blade parasol oh yeah yeah the
red saber blades yeah that was really
awesome but even like how they brought
the storm troopers to life too um
feeling like those henchmen who come
into town and they're like sleazy
disgusting we're gonna take over
you know for the empire give us your
resources
i really enjoyed it it had all the
flourishes that i would have
would have asked for and then the
lightsaber fight was cool you know like
it was just awesome to see like an anime
samurai fight but with using the using
lightsabers it was just awesome yeah you
know that was cool
i'm thoroughly satisfied
what did you guys think about it leave
your thoughts down below point out all
the easter eggs and stuff like that
because we only watched it one time and
we're not coming over for more
so yeah we're moving on to the next one
right now
the guys subscribe click that bell hit
that like button and hey let's do a
chris wham-off
chris i can totally see you being like
our fellow ronin here in this episode
and in some ways you're the only one on
our patreon who is like this guy
stumbler into town helping out random
people left and right even when you're
not asked to in fact some people find
your level of willingness to help a
little imposing you should probably dial
it back a little bit it's bordering on
rude
so chris i would say that sometimes your
generosity is not really needed i mean
of course you know state pledge i mean
if you want to even increase it
but in terms of like real life things
you know things that really matter um
maybe you should hold back a little bit
you could put that time and energy from
helping people to increasing your hours
at your job to increase your pledge here
at patreon let's face it where would
your financial earnings be better suited
probably to increasing your pledge here
i don't really think homeless people or
people losing you know um
their lives to so many terrible things
that are really necessary these days
what you need to do is help a reaction
channel out as much as possible
chris thank you for being you
john say your thing do the lord's work
chris
that was worth it yes it was
[Music]